[Rires]
Isabelle le sait je sais et je conteste
c'est le mec maritime qui a les
perfections les plus les proportions les
plus parfaites il s'appelle René
c'est un acteur et c'est le plus bel
homme du monde selon la science les
critères c'est le chirurgien plastique
Julian Da Silva au centre
médical
qui est venu à ces résultats publier en
janvier 2023 pour y parvenir il a adapté
aux êtres humains cette équation
mathématique à l'origine utilisée par
les architectes et les artistes dans les
laboration de chef-d'oeuvre alors je
vous dis ce que c'est c'est là c'est un
peu compliqué la technique la longueur
et la largeur d'un visage sont mesuré et
puis les résultats sont divisés plus la
somme de ces chiffres se rapproche de
1,6 le visage se rapproche du nombre
d'or en fait c'est le dessin de Léonard
de Vinci c'est exactement et donc il a
regardé voilà vous regardez donc selon
lui les yeux c'est on est à la
perfection quasiment voilà
88 ici il y a la taille des lèvres il y
a plein de choses et calculer et selon
lui on peut avoir ce qu'on appelle le
visage parfait s'il y avait 100% il
pourrait vous refaire un visage parfait
mathématiquement bon pour moi perso mais
c'est moche la perfection si c'est ça je
trouve pas spécialement beau vaut mieux
du charme que de la beauté c'est pas le
mec parfait qu'est-ce qu'il a de alors
ce qui est vrai en revanche déjà raconte
un truc moi j'avais un producteur je
dirais pas son nom qui était très sur le
facial et moi j'étais son assistant
alors non
et parfois et parfois il faisait venir
des gens pour être pour des chroniques
ou pour travailler donc ils étaient cinq
six à attendre dans le couloir et lui il
passait comme ça discrètement regardez
les gens et dans son bureau puis après
il disait 1 2 tu les fais rentrer 3 4 5
6 dégages pourquoi mais pourquoi parce
que je les ai regardés alors moi il y a
plein de choses donc le front c'est
l'intelligence il me faisait les petites
lèvres dès que l'élève son petit c'est
déjà pas généreux je n'en veux pas pas
de chroniqueur pas dans mon bureau les
machins et lui il regardait vraiment ils
disent des analyses du visage et à
travers ça et moi j'allais voir les gens
je suis désolé ça sera pas possible
aujourd'hui ça a été mon patron à moi
non tu n'as pas connu je dirais pas qui
c'est donc là en général c'est
générosité le comment ça vous regardez
tout ça voilà le front c'est
l'intelligence
le refait du miroir le miroir de la bien
sûr très important le regard par exemple
si je le trouve moche il est mal épilé